[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi je vais vous raconter tout une autre
histoire qui va commencer par les murs
d'abidjan dans les années 70 les murs
étaient bas progressivement qu'elles
sont a commencé à observer
on a commencé à observer des murs avec
des là un peu de ferraille de protection
et puis progressivement
c'est devenu des barbelés ça veut dire
que on se porte très bien dans la maison
ensuite des barbelés c'est devenu un
système électrique
ça veut dire qu'on se porte encore mieux
dans la maison et que tout va bien
dans le quartier on s'enferme les
ménages investissent de plus en plus
dans les sociétés de gardiennage
non content de tout ça on emmène un
système électronique qui parsèment la
ville
tout ça se compte qu'ils les rebelles de
ses murs et de ses systèmes
électroniques que sont les enfants
microbes
c'est exactement
lorsqu'on dit les microbes sont là si je
lui dis tout de suite
la salle se vide en moins de deux
minutes
c'est comme si je disais à la fois aux
barres
[Applaudissements]
alors ces enfants j'ai décidé d'aller
comprendre pour moi ils sont devenus ce
qu'ils sont
quelle a été la logique de basculement
dans la violence
leur perception de la société leur
avenir
j'ai pris ma caméra j'ai utilisé les
méthodes de pénétration des milieux à
risques
je vous assure parfois il m'arrivait de
trembler quand j'étais avec eux et que
il faisait des mouvements que je ne
comprenais pas bref bref il fallait
aller jusqu'au bout de l'opération et
ils m'ont appris ce que c'est que les
machettes les matches est celle là c'est
leur instrument d'écriture
c'est leur façon de signer leur présence
dans une société
ils m'ont appris le match est mais c'est
des corps marqué ces enfants qu'on
appelle les microbes c'est des corps et
des esprits marquer ils sont marqués par
l'environnement dans lequel vivent ce
sont des zones y vivent dans les zones
de relégation
ils vivent dans une espèce d'exil
intérieur
voyez ce quartier et puis quand on
essaye d'approcher les familles c'est on
est en plein déni de droit ils n'ont pas
droit à l'eau ils n'ont pas droit à
l'électricité nos droits a rien du tout
généralement ces enfants naissent et
grandissent dans des familles
décomposées souvent monoparentales à la
charge de la seule mère qui est souvent
la seule personne adulte présente à la
maison c'est souvent des enfants ce sont
des des enfants en rupture avec le
système scolaire
ce sont en fait des produits avorté
système éducatif et qui se retrouve
évidemment dans les rues la rue les
prend en charge
comme ils le disent eux-mêmes la rue
devienne leur famille mais curieusement
tous les enfants microbes que j'ai
rencontré il adore une figure du cinéma
brésilien
on appelle ces péquignot apparemment
vous connaissez péquignot répète qu'il
n'y ont tous ses enfants la connaissent
des pics you
il considère et péquignot comme une
idole et pétillon les a inspirés ces
enfants connaissent ce qu'on appelle
l'expérience de la désespérance sociale
ils ont un frère aîné qui a fait les
diplômes à l'université d'abidjan de
bouaké de daloa qui est au chômage
depuis trois ans quatre ans ils ne
croient plus à l'école
là on est dans un quartier à youpougon
lundi à 10 heures du matin
alors face à l'impuissance de leurs
parents ses enfants décident d'aller
dans la rue on distille se débrouiller
mais lorsqu'ils arrivent dans la rue ils
sont pris en charge par ce qu'on appelle
le boni savait ce qu'on appelle le moins
qu'est ce que le bruit le groupe
mais le bruit dans la culture de la
bande et inspirateur de contrevaleur de
ressources de solidarité et de
fraternité pour des enfants qui sont
désocialisées
mais qui en allant dans la rue entre
dans un processus de socialisation par
la rue la première chose qu'ils
apprennent c'est consommer la drogue
consommé la drogue
et comme ils le disent eux mêmes
progressivement on les emmène dans ce
qu'ils appellent les doses forte
j'ai passé des moments de frayeur dans
l'est d'aller dans les ghettos où vous
voyez ces enfants vous vous passez la
veille vous les voyez endormi à 9h le
lendemain à 10h ils sont pas encore
réveillé tellement ils sont abîmés par
la drogue qu'ils estiment que lorsqu'on
a fini de consommer la drogue
on peut faire l'incroyable d'où le titre
du documentaire la culture de la match
est et inculquer justement dans le
ghetto la maquette on ne la manipule pas
n'importe comment
il ya des techniques de gestion de la
maquette lorsqu'on est sur un territoire
de chasse
je vous rappelle que c'est des enfants
qui ont entre 10 et 18 ans ils sont
d'une intelligence redoutable il y a
tout simplement à s'intéresser aux
techniques de maillage des territoires
aux opérations chirurgicales qu'il mène
en fonction des territoires
ils s'organisent jamais aux personnes au
minimum en groupes de quatre et entre 80
ils sont capables de ceinture et un
quartier et d'opérer en quelques minutes
et d'en ressortir sans qu'on ne puisse
les apercevoir
mais pour arriver à faire l'incroyable
il faut il faut construire les
ressources de l'invincibilité série glee
mais avec eux j'ai enrichi au
vocabulaire ça ne s'appelle pas que gris
gris là bas ça s'appelle les solutions
laiterie bardi les un coup bah ouais moi
visiblement il ya quelque chose de plus
que vous puisque je suis à les enrichir
mon vocabulaire dans un univers dont
vous avez peur alors ses enfants le
considèrent que lorsque ils sont
protégés par les solutions attaché de
haut en bas
ils peuvent faire tout ce qu'ils veulent
ils sont en situation d'invisibilité
et pour cela ils disent aller jusqu'au
village pour se protéger le village qui
arrivait du souvent c'est korhogo ça
veut dire que si vous avez des amis
korhogolais rapprochez-vous 2 ils ont
des choses puisque les enfants les ont
identifiés comme tels
alors ils estiment que sous l'effet des
solutions ils n'ont plus peur de rien à
part dieu heureusement heureusement
parce que s'ils n'ont plus peur de rien
il ya de quoi s'inquiéter et c'est là
que je découvre le haine vis-à-vis de la
société ils en veulent la société ils
disent en vouloir à la société il en
veut le boss ce qu'ils appellent les
bosses et ils vont loin ils disent que
le posse gang près du million et qu' ils
ne savent rien de ce qui se passe dans
le pays même si ça va être que le boss
c'est un beau sky et plus du million
qu'elle s'il allait faire alors alors
pour eux c'est bath s'accapare de
l'argent ne redistribue pas et du coup
ils se trouvent privés de ressources
il insiste sur le fait que ces boss du
chrtr rien alors dans ces conditions ils
ne voient leur avenir que dans le vol et
ceux à qui s'en prennent aux 6 et des
policiers il estime que les policiers
viennent apprendre des trucs qu'ils on
voulait les intercepte et partage de but
et avec eux
alors on est face à des jeunes révoltés
contre les sociétés mais en même temps
ils ont beaucoup de coeur ils ont le
souci de le moment les rebelles sont ils
parlent abondamment de leur mère pour
ceux dont les mères sont encore vivantes
là ils s'en prennent par exemple au
maire qui selon un châssis au moment des
trottoirs le moment qui mènent leur
petite activité et qu'elle ne mérite pas
ça alors ces enfants regardent tout ça
estime qu' ils ont là des raisons de se
révolter parce que ça le ferait mal
parfois lorsqu'il vous parle leur voix
tremblante
c'est vraiment l'esprit le sentiment de
révolte vis-à-vis de la société et c'est
pourquoi il estime qu' il faut qu'il
brouille
il faut qu'il joue il faut que il
brouille pour faire vivre leur famille
et le moyen qu'ils ont trouvé
c'est d'aller agresser données volées le
pire c'est qu'ils considèrent ce qu'ils
font comme une activité économique comme
n'importe quelle activité
c'est ça le plus grave ils le font parce
que ils veulent faire manger leur petit
frère il veut soigner le moment voyez il
ya quand même une part d'humanité dans
l'inhumanité qu'on observe avec ses
enfants
ils veulent pouvoir un jour aider les
pauvres
lorsqu'ils auront les moyens ils ont ils
ont même eu le souci de l'autre ils
agressent certains et ils ont le souci
d'autres c'est quand même assez
ambivalent comme attitude
et ils ont ils se prennent du pitié par
exemple pour les femmes les femmes d'un
certain âge en situation de
vulnérabilité physique
tout ça pour vous dire malgré la
violence qui les habitent
ils ont encore une part d'humanité en
eux ils parlent même de pleurer lorsque
ils voient ces femmes dans leur
incapacité et il estime que si un jour
dieu les aide à devenir quelqu'un ils
vont travailler à changer les choses
pour moi c'est un message que je voulais
vous faire passer dans ces jeunes il y
encore une humanité il est important
qu'on agisse d maintenant on pense aller
récupérer de cette situation et c'est
possible
comment y arriver il faut discriminer
positivement les enfants qui sont dans
des zones que l'on sait être des zones
fragiles des zones de vulnérabilité et à
la géographie de la pauvreté dans le
milieu urbain
discriminer positivement ça veut dire
quoi
si on dépense 10 francs à cocody il faut
pouvoir dépenser 15 francs abobo pour
espérer sorti ses enfants de cette
situation pourquoi parce que à cocody
les enfants sont déposés à l'école par
les parents eux on doit pouvoir assurer
le transport eux on doit leur assurer la
continuité paul poux qu'il mange parce
que ses enfants ne mangent pas vous avez
bien vu de l'environnement dans lequel
ils évoluent ils vivent
il faut pas continuer a réagi au
phénomène par la presse
la simple approche sécuritaire il faut
agir
rires je dis bien il faut pas seulement
réagir mais il faut agir agir ça veut
dire quoi aller vers des politiques
publiques qui favorise justement cette
discrimination positive en faveur des
enfants
il est important de restaurer l'autorité
parentale
oui j'en appelle aux religieux qui
s'intéressent à ce genre de phénomène
qui travaille à cela tu essayes de faire
vivre une idée de famille mais également
les politiques publiques qui favorise
l'accès à l'emploi l'accès aux revenus
parce que vous vous imaginez un parent
qui n'est plus en mesure de subvenir aux
besoins de ses enfants ne peut pas avoir
d'autorité sur ses enfants
je donne souvent l'exemple les chiens en
afrique en afrique vous appelez un chien
mais d'or vous le voyez sur les tas
d'ordures qui bouge vous l'appelez
médias il ne répond pas mais parce que
vous ne lui donnez pas à manger mais
regardez les chiens en europe
ils connaissent même le klaxon de leurs
maîtres
c'est là la différence vous ne pouvez
pas exercer d'autorité par tad paternel
si vous ne mobiliser pas les ressources
de cette autorité
eh ben comment maîtriser les ressources
c'est le revenu qui permettent de
subvenir aux besoins des enfants
vous avez vu la zone de relégation dans
lesquelles vivent ces ménages comment
peut-on avoir un esprit je ne parle pas
du saint-esprit je parle de l'esprit un
esprit sain dans un corps sain
lorsqu'on vit dans un environnement
comme celui là pour finir je vous dirai
ceci la politique sécuritaire à elle
toute seule ne pourra pas nous permettre
d'aller jusqu'au bout de ce phénomène il
faut une approche beaucoup plus globale
dans laquelle vous pourrez vous investir
à tous les niveaux
vous vous trouvez parce qu'il faut pas
laisser cette problématique
seul à l'état ce n'est pas normal que
dans une société des enfants tuent des
adultes et que les adultes de 10 tués
l'est dans quelle société somme non est
ce que c'est un environnement viable que
cet environnement dans lequel tout le
monde sent ferme comme je voulais
montrer tout à l'heure un environnement
dans lequel les enfants deviennent une
source de risque importantes pour les
populations
j'ai dit mon soirée
[Applaudissements]